a western-led price cab on Russian oil
entered effect today drawing the ire of
Moscow and adding another Kink to Global
oil markets the European Union and G7
Nations agreeing to a ceiling of 60
dollars a barrel over the weekend under
the new rules Western shipping and
insurance firms must abide by the price
cap for future transactions Moscow vowed
again on Sunday to stop all oil sales to
Nations participating in the cap
all right for more let's bring in
Mikhail kutikin he's an independent
energy analyst uh welcome to the program
Mikhail this price cap is meant to curb
Russia's wartime revenues will it
yes it definitely will we already see
that direction officials responded to
the price camp and to the Embargo today
with the two declarations and both
declarations are absolutely meaningless
first they said that they are not going
to deliver oil to the countries that
join the price kept scheme and those
countries have already stopped importing
all Russian crude oil so it's um it
doesn't make sense to to make such
threads the next thread is from Russia
or Russia is going to decrease oil
production and thus influence the global
oil Market in response to the the new
measures well if Russia cannot sell its
oil oil companies under us are already
decreasing production without any uh
well special orders from the current
this is a natural process Michael what
about a big time customers like India
and China and turkey would they be able
to sort of jump in and just buy more of
Russian oil
I do not think it is possible first for
China there is transportation bottle
next bottle bottlenecks and China Canada
receive more oil that it has been
receiving for several years before which
is limited to to a slightly less than 2
million barrels per day and the country
is just unable to increase its intake of
Russian oil as to India it is also under
pressure of possible sanctions and The
Irregular suppliers of crude oil to
India such as Iraq and other countries
of the Persian Gulf are already
promising to offer discounts which would
be about ten dollars less than the
recent price of oil and so in the alone
cannot compensate the loss of the
European market yes turkey will take
some additional oil but not much uh you
mentioned it there an EO Embargo of
Russian oil shipped by sea is coming uh
to effect today so how much of an impact
does this have
yes Russia has well problems with the
exported that oil which the European
countries the G7 the United States are
not going to accept and uh According to
some rumors Russia is buying some
Obsolete and uh very old oil tankers and
provided them with insurance by Russian
companies to keep transporting oil to
outside markets but first such markets
well I do not think that they exist in
the well in the scope that Russia holds
to sell its oil and I think there will
be just occasional attempts to by uh
right to uh well to break the rules of
the G7 and the uh European Union
energy analyst thank you
as we just discussed along with a price
cab and EU import ban on Russian oil
delivered by ship has been in effect
since today meaning new shipments will
be embargoed crude that's already
underway still be accepted here's more
on the likely impacts of this move
an oil tanker on its way to a European
port a site that should become rarer in
the weeks ahead as of December 5th new
Russian oil shipments to Europe are
officially banned the move is the latest
EU effort to Target Russian fossil fuel
revenues more than two-thirds of Russian
oil exports to the EU arrive via sea but
soon no more
Germany will continue to import Russian
oil through the drushpa pipeline but
only through the end of the year
Hungary Slovakia and the Czech Republic
will also continue to rely on pipelines
they argue they have no alternative to
Russian oil
the widespread boycott is a reaction to
Russia's ongoing war in Ukraine so how
is it affecting the market substitution
was already quite successful I mean oil
is a fungible commodity so basically you
can sell and buy on the World Market and
that's what Europe did basically it
bought oil from other sources just as
Russia tried to redirect its sales
um to other buyers Brent crude was
trading around 40 dollars per barrel at
the beginning of the covid-19 pandemic
it soared to 120 dollars a barrel last
summer before falling below one hundred
dollars
European reserves are bursting at the
seams new Supply contracts have been
signed and oil prices are declining
and that has been basically to do with
two things the first is the the fear of
U.S and Eurozone
um uh recession
um so the lower slower economic growth
which would lead to less demand for oil
that's pushing prices down and the other
aspect is um the the Chinese lockdowns
the ban has Ripple effects an end to
Russian oil flaws will be a huge problem
for pck refinery in the Eastern German
Town of schwed which was supplied via
the grouchpal pipeline
there is a replacement
pipeline from the rostock harbor coming
to Schmidt however it only has about 50
percent of the capacity of the drusband
pipeline so this question has yet to be
answered by the German government how
the how they're going to proceed to make
the um to keep the refinery running
even if the refinery in schwet operates
at 50 capacity Germany's crude Supply
isn't at risk plans call for gas
stations to be supplied with petrol and
Diesel from other European countries